hi this is a Sadashiva pipe from science
mission so today we have a doc big black
Dasgupta with us he dr. Dasgupta is a
associate professor of pediatrics and a
member of the division of oncology at
the Cincinnati Children's Hospital
so his research focuses on understanding
mechanisms of cancer development and
progression so dr. Gupta Dasgupta has
published several articles in
peer-reviewed journals and he has
several grants to his credit he is also
in the editorial board of few of the
journals now welcome dr. Dasgupta hands
and ah thank you thank you so can you
please talk about yourself your
background and uh what do you want to
restart for whenever like you are
education everything maybe in few
sentences so school
and then I finished my college and my
masters and then made it by page from
Indiana Chemical Biology which is a
flagship of the recent Institute of
comfort of India so after finishing my
PhD I moved to the US as a divided
postdoctoral training at Washington
University in st. Louis if so my primary
interest and post are for training was
neuroscience so basically brained up and
and development of brain tumors so I
studied you know cancer cell signaling
of signaling normal neural cells the
glial cells astrocytes and I also
studied for example the role of
different tumor suppressors the first
tumor suppressor that I worked on was
called nf1
so I studied the role of man if one in
the development of opting athlete Loomis
in mice and so this is a so since then
we also worked on the role of this you
know by energetic sensor it's called
baby kinase this is a this is a central
energy sensor ourselves and this is a
very interesting enzyme a very
controversial one though because a lot
of its function was not known when I
started particularly to roll the
development in cancer so I started
working on this design and he made
several you know form discoveries we
found under Tilly in your presentation
what they discovered he made the role of
a became cancer but he also found that
it was expressed in the brain and the
tissues and it's inhibits in TOR see one
but many lessons that he processes we
figured out the role of in pain during
brain development and then after
finishing my close up or training they
moved to Cincinnati Children's Hospital
which is I would say the top top three
pediatric hospitals in the country so he
removed in 2009 as a tenure-track
assistant professor and then I roasted
the ranks and now I am a tenured
associate professor at suspensions and
my research is primarily you know is
focused on understanding the role of a
kinase and the bioenergetics and
metabolomics of of human cancer and we
use primarily brain tumor as model okay
talk about your lab
and your student center because I really
small to medium size lab generally we
had an opportunity postdocs we wanted to
graduate students but one or two rigid
assistants and I always had the fortune
of you know undergraduate students who
for whatever reasons they kind of like I
don't like me or not but he's like the
kind of research we do so he always had
a bunch of undergraduates push me the
training my lab I think I probably train
between undergraduates and some high
school students also I would say 3035
trained various times and can like I
know you are busy with the research so
can you please talk about your
extracurricular activities like URL and
so you play or whatever like just to
take your mind off of the hard work yeah
so it's it's not easy to take a work way
of mind I mean we need your offices for
the same time the work never reaches
this is just a major of beef so I love
to play tennis I honestly don't get much
time though but I religious runner I try
to run as much as I can both outdoor and
sometimes if the weather is too harsh a
one in the order at the gym I do some
freestyle little light weight workouts
which you know I try not to miss say you
know four to five days a week they do
this when I try to run mostly in the
summer or you know throughout the year
and they take my running shoes where I
go to you know meetings instead of this
I had hobby I'm trying to revive the
Holi in which this photography how
expensive camera so have the gadgets I
just don't have the time the iPhone is
replacing all cameras as you know so I
have two clients revive my hobby I
really enjoy and coming back to the
research and you were career so can you
please talk about some of the people who
supported you men told you to help you
in your career so I start in other who
earlier I had the fortune of being
tutored by this fascinating teachers in
India there was one teacher in my high
school and there was at least one or two
teachers in my college and please don't
say to teachers masters taught us you
know evolution chemistry genetics
molecular biology so those you know I
would say some of these teachers really
inspired me not only not only to learn
how to teach but to understand how
exciting the subjects are I would say
they played a very important role in
pushing me incoming basic science I mean
when people ask me what could you become
because scientist I say I would probably
become a neurosurgeon dad was I think I
thought I was going to be that but
Indian didn't happen so I came to basic
science and I fall in love with it and
if you ask me today that you know those
teachers made tremendous contribution
and you know you might have the contrary
I would say during my
postdoctoral but the different PT and I
think my PhD mentor dr. Roy in Calcutta
he was a very installation he was very
hands-off and he gave he who gave me the
freedom to do anything whatever I want
to do so I learned a lot I failed a lot
but I learned a lot I would say I got
excellent postdoctoral mentors in last
year and the captain dr. brand
so both David and Jeff are an excellent
mentor there are different styles but I
you know I was able to publish good work
go to the labs and then I would say when
I moved to Cincinnati Children's as
faculty you know it's a huge deal to
start a new lab and you first
crowdfunded I will name one person name
is Kenneth Campbell he was really
instrumental in guiding me to get my
first one I I'm not sure what where I
stand without Kenny's really active
participation in health and Kenny's not
in our department but you know I mean
since the Anna students is a place where
people help out each other you know it
goes you know it cuts through the
boundaries of the department actually so
Kane really helped ease I would say his
mentorship is something that we'll never
forget
and the coming back to the can be
searched so can you please talk little
bit new some preview of what we are
talking about and give you a
presentation please yeah
so there are many projects in the short
time I've chosen to discuss just you
know this such security projects which
are related they're all brain tumor
related projects
I have other projects both
cancer-related normal brain development
projects of a benefit of time I will not
discuss that today but today what I'm
going to tell you is when we started or
lab the question about the specific
molecule called a kinase whether this
molecule this is about energetic sensor
whether the sensor is tumor suppressor
wear or rephrase it whether it
suppresses cancer or tumor development
or it is it is plated protein or old so
there was a lot of controversy on the
subject and that is the subject that I
found very exciting and interesting and
challenging so we took up this matter
and we started the experiments and I
will show you what the field was like
ten years ago and how the fields evolved
because of respect from our lab and many
other labs that work during this ten
years to show that you know the fields
kind of evolving very fast so I can show
you know they should go ahead so so do
you want me to go to this lecture yeah
okay let me know if you can see it can
you see it
not yet no okay wait let me just
yeah you can see it right now yeah you
can go to the presentation mode yeah
all right cool so what do you see here
now are on the left and the right are
you can see that the presentation right
yeah okay so on the left and right you
can see there's the left so we have
cleared the brain is called a brain
clearance technique so we've cleared the
brain and it made it left you can see
the normal blood vessels of the brain
tissue you can see there's a certain
structure and certain form a certain
pattern right on the right you can see
that the white circles are the tumor
cells the brain tumor cells there's a
human brain tumor show that you planted
and you can see in the green are a
highly abnormal tumor vasculature
basically here isn't normal
it is already known so we are just to
the brain clearance we can if you see
this very clearly in 3d that
house-trained in abnormal this
vasculature inside the tumors and the
red dots are potentially hemorrhage
because in the brain tumors you know
this was our brilliant normal and they
rupture and the release his blood that's
called hemorrhaging hemorrhage is very
common feature of it was some other
bring him a little study so here is
showing that the vasculature is highly
abnormal and the keep inside the tumor
and there's hemorrhage insulative right
so in the next slide what I'm gonna show
you is is what if she is a cartoon of a
cancer cell and the cancer cells can I
use of my pointer are yeah so you can
see the cartoon of a cancer cell you can
see these are some of the genes that are
amplified
potentially oncogenes and these are that
you must press her that are getting that
Liam in cancer so a cell particularly
that you know the cancer cell that needs
are higher they have two essential needs
one is about synthetic need and one is
about energetic need so they need you
lose a lot of energy and use that energy
to synthesize a lot of micro molecules
and in doing so in order to do all this
cancer cells undergo metabolic
reprogramming and there's a rewiring of
the signal transduction pathways and
several metabolic pathways and it'll
crossed out the constant crosstalk
between the tonic pathways and the
signal transduction pathways and I think
it's a cancer cell survival really
critically it's dependent upon balance
because the immune system is really
hostile to the tumor cells so they have
to evade from the host immune system
okay and so so the goal of the body is
to kill the cancer cell in the objective
of the cancer cell is to proliferate and
survive so as they proliferate the tumor
actually becomes very big and there's a
lot of stress that builds inside the
tumor and it is it there's a lot of
natural death inside so the tumor has to
make a balance because it has to live
any place once and if it was to spread
so I think it's appropriate balance
between
proliferation and survival really
determines if a tumor is going to
survive or not
or in other words if it'll be if you'll
be able to you know spread the disease
that kill the patient so so I want to
tell you about this one kinase that is
really important to provide and support
about bioenergetic need of the cancer
cells and this enzyme is called ap
activated protein kinase or apk this
actually activates
about energetic pathways while it
actually blocks by something
uh so the way aap kinase works is it's
kind of like uh if you imagine your cell
as a car and it has got a gas pedal and
it's got brake so the gas pedal is for
example the molecules that drive the car
and these are all the molecules that
drive biosynthesis
for example mTOR c1 is one of this gas
pellets but if you keep your foot on the
gas for a very long time and used to me
I love cats so there has to be somebody
you know to play the brakes NP Canas the
brake so it allows the cells to
constantly gauge how much of fuel is
there and depending on how much fuel is
there it's actually balances the speed
of the car so if you're a cancer cell it
allows the cells to survive during you
know periods of energy stress okay so it
slows down the cell and when there is
plenty of energy or food available
you know the footage taken off the gas
pedal ously become is an analogy NP
kinase will be inactivated and the cells
can do processes so indicates present in
all organisms it is an evolutionary
conserved cellular energy sensor and
it's the hub for sin or tablet
controlled if it is a three it has got
three it's a heterodimer consisting of
alpha beta and gamma spirits multiple
alpha beta gamma spirits so when in a
normal cell that is which maintains a
high ATP to MP ratio that causes an
allosteric inhibition of in became aa
but when this energy stress there is
allosteric activation in P binds to this
gamma subunit and there is allosteric
activation of a PK
what it does it allows a conformational
change in this cattle in the alpha
subunit that allows phosphorylation by
an option kinase called lkb1
and this actually causes full activation
there's another method of activation of
a PDA is potentially energy independent
we are not completely sure about it it
is calcium dependent and it is done by a
kinase called cam kinase kinase beta
you see calcium calmodulin kinase beta
and it's also you know there are a
couple papers of showing the very event
called tgf-beta after the kinase attack
one can also phosphor at a PK alpha at
the same site fully activated but when
NB gets fully activated there is energy
homeostasis so how I what it happens is
that what happens is that this
implicated phosphoric a lot of
substrates and it causes you know both
immediately and chronically prescription
is also affected so ultimately there's
energy in stasis so this is how I am
became a perfect self attack cells
during stress so as I said before that
ap key inhibits our synthetic processes
or our anabolism anabolism consumes ATP
so when there is energy stress and decay
will block annapolis own so that not a
whole lot of ATP is consumed and how he
does it for example it inhibits fatty
acid biosynthesis
it is cholesterol synthesis the key
participants rebels about synthesis
protein synthesis by phosphorylating
all these substrates and inhibiting them
at the same time in PK also promotes
catabolism catabolism of the processes
where and more ATP is produced so in
became one hand suppresses ATP
consumption and the other hand actually
allows production and if the way does it
is actually augment fatty acid oxidation
could be ATP it actually promotes
glycolysis although how it does promote
Collison controversial it promotes
energy production by augmenting
mitochondria oxidative phosphorylation
although holly does being a commercial
it also allows the cells to survive
stress through mechanism ecology and it
also sells like various other mechanisms
these allow cells survive
Basia and nutrient stress some studies
say that indicates also migration and
resistance of many drugs and cinematix
so because NPK blocks these by synthetic
processes for example lipid synthesis
and protein synthesis by living in poor
you know for a very long time as I was
standing before for a very long time
agents that activity implicate for
example you know forming Foreman
particularly metformin is a drug that is
used for the management of type 2
diabetes I think it's probably the most
well known drug of the field of diabetes
is prescribed in millions of people and
people have used but forming and forming
other agents like a car and you know
many other agents so these are all these
agents actually to throw the cells if
you said throw this agent to the cells
and its own culture they will activate a
PK and so what this aliens did in one
hand activated a PK and also suppress
through its rich and it was viewed for a
long time that the suppression of cell
proliferation by these agents is because
of a big activation so that's why in
peak it was thought to be part of the
tumor suppressor pattern but whether
this growth suppressive effects of this
reagents we're actually you know going
to NPK all this present effects really
specific for indicator or not it's not
really for a study so for many many
years I would say you know the several
papers that
showed you know in decay is part of a
team expressive pathway so when we
started working when we started working
we we found that cancer cells actually
Express a lot of many cancers Express
you know in a copious amount of
activating the cables
so we questioned whether you know the
this compounds is I Carbon Farming and
raised red compounds that actually
suppress cephalic version these effect
of proliferation a be dependent or
independent so as you can see here and
this is a this is the untreated cells
and these two are this is though
different role cell and this is a cell
that doesn't express any bkb acusada de
piqi here and so the cells with this
with this brick pattern other cells that
we have silenced to indicate but you can
see that when you add this reagents this
icon informing you can see that
regardless of apks presence or absence
these reagents are capable of producing
the proliferation from control to here
and for control to here it doesn't
matter
the this compound does not discriminate
between cells that have or do not have
implicit so it feels shows that the
agents you know agents do suppress
separation does it I mean independent we
have done the same experiment in normal
cells these are brain tumor cells and
normal cells and if all the same in fact
that the suppressive growth
proliferation suppressing effect on
these videos are now we took the study
in vivo and you can see here so these
are tumors that are grown in the flank
of animals of mice it's a control tumor
now if you treat this animals with a car
orbit forming the same agent that
activating McKay you can see all these
four tumors are smaller than the control
but the important point here is that the
cells the tumors
that were derived from cells that we
have actually silenced apk there also
suppress the growth is also suppressed
by this region it's clearly showing that
in peak is probably not required for the
growth suppressive effect of President
Petrov is created so
we also found that you know mid for men
which shown to really block in Russia
one through and kinase because this was
the pathway that was born before that
make foreman will activate a decay and
then through see sc2 and raft or made
farming who actually impotent or as you
know as part of the part of metformin
grows presence but what he found is that
here the two readouts of tour c1
activation is phosphorylation of s6 and
phosphorylation of for unity bond you
can see that this is a control empty
cell and this is an implicit silencer
you can see the bit forming can block
phosphorylation of s6 regardless of
implicit right so again showing
mechanistically that effect of metformin
is blocking it or can be independent of
implicit at least in this context so and
then so performing is known as a
mitochondrial complex one inhibitor and
there is there's no between about it so
as you can see that when you actually
treat the cells with metformin
okar is the respiration of this is the
readout of the respiration of results
you can see when you had met forming the
reservation goes down here and as there
is patience goes down on the cells try
to compensate for the loss of ATP in
respiration by boosting yeah click hosts
and eke hard as you can see is a measure
of glycolysis so as you add in informing
the respiration goes down while the
glycolysis goes
so even this effect are performing this
compensator II glycolysis is also we
found is independent and see that here
but farming is adding bit farming
because us as companies that are
increasingly ecologist and it happens
Boldin indicate proficient may be
deficient so it's clearly showing that
all is to be published his paper in 2014
in pns and we were to move on see what
sir watch the status may be kinase in
tumor that we are really interested in
it's called but so long as you know it's
highly thought easy building adult and
the pediatric population I mean nobody
really survive disease so what we found
so we we analyzed the tumor cell atlas
so this is the way you can see the
experience we get to be you can examine
the expression level of the genes of
interest so this is GBM responses no one
brain as you can see that so these are
the different civilian survey indicate
alpha and be a one and get one so you
can see the comparative normal brain in
the tumor in decay expression is pretty
high now we found the same thing
a normal human exercise that he got to
be by and if you maintain them in your
lab compared to normal human astrocytes
these are the brain glial cells for the
norman counterparts compared to these
cells you can see that the patient here
i'd primary GBM lines they had high
amount of activate became and indicating
phosphorylates a couple substrates are
shown here one is a selector boxes
wrapped or so more phosphate became
means more activate decay and more
activate became it's more
phosphorylation of substance as you can
see here we saw the same thing when the
protein license of fresh GBM tissue that
we actually we collaborate with nearest
3:10 also near surgeons and other labs
toward the world and we procure the
tissues frozen tissues and we make
protein lysis and you can see that in
most tissues compared to the normal
brain this is first to the normal brain
with the same peak a pathway is pretty
active these two disciples g3 ng8 the
samples of de gradients we can see the
approaching - so this is like
immunohistochemistry of human label so
you can see this brown staining is very
high activity the tumors is a
quantification of the phosphate but your
academic signal compared to normal brain
this is humorous another brain showing
very high indica signal and this is this
is a genetically engineered mouse model
of of high-grade glioma and you can see
in this tumors in big activity is pretty
high so you can see any anywhere you
have a high-grade glioma be it in a
mouse frame or in a human brain you see
high level of activity so we want to
know what is this high implicated to be
doing so we as you see here so this is a
primary brain tumor cell that is
temporarily be adhered them to monitor
ptosis and mitosis so this is a normal
cells so you can see that you can keep
an eye the cells to be the one with
green dot you will see the cells will
pop up and will divide into two cells
just at normal district cancer cell
normally divides so you can see just
divided into two cells now if you see
this video these are cells that we have
silenced named kindness so we can just
keep an eye on anybody but particularly
draw your attention on this blue dog
this yellow dog circles see what happens
it was what you can see that these cells
not having NPK would just pop up and
burst and showing a sign of apoptosis so
loss of a became causes the process or a
tumor cells so we have done this
experiment in many
jamia mines they can see that it is not
control and if you silence EPK the cells
really don't wanna grow very well and we
have used in decades
this is shRNA to let the virus this is
si RNA this more acutely down lately
okay
we saw very similar of fact we used a
dominant negative apk and also CRISPR so
multiple and mom by using multiple
methods we show that the so most cell
lines for a nice primaries are lines the
bitter expectations it be easily
required from by Libyans so interpreting
vivo and as you can see that so these
are the control see the control animals
and you can see that they were
transplanted with Lucifer is labeled
cell so you can monitor the growth of
the tumor longitudinally you can see
this is day six
this small children developing by day
nine everybody got tumor 12 you can see
almost all I'm almost getting to murder
but the cells don't have a NPK the tumor
growth development is it's significantly
as you can see here the controllers
which RNA by this routine everybody that
has a huge human and they have utilized
while you know the tumor growth is
delayed by many days I can see this is
about 35 days ago tumor and these two
animals especially women keep afraid so
this is a survival curve we can showing
that if you the two lines we have done
even four lines now that the control
mice with control to merge with
indicating they die much sooner than
mice with tumors will suppress him so to
clearly shows both in people in vitro
and in vivo he plays an important role
in human growth and survival so what is
the mechanism you know we need RNA seek
analysis to understand what is going on
in the cells in terms of expression of
genes which knockdown in decay and to
our pleasant surprise we found that one
of the pathways that was down regulated
so this is a McKay
proficiency
deficient the student lines you can seem
that glycolysis pathway is downregulated
silence if he came and did a several
genes that we found to be dominated
really really suppressing together and
we are validating these results with RNA
and protein levels in vitro and in the
tumor this is the pathway analysis to
show that central to this pathways if
one alpha that is you know critical for
the transcription of almost all genes
required for my crosses another pathway
that we found down regulated following
embarrassing was mikeandjill populations
you can see that there are public
processes article the description my
complement activation is there all done
regulated you can know that a hideous
function but still very controversial
about how okay mechanistic me how his so
we found that it knows the several genes
that are down regulated one of them was
critical called T fan which is found to
be this is a massive transcription
factor for both mitochondrial DNA
replication and my Genesis microglia
transcriptions so in the pathway
analysis we found that there is a
transcription factor on gab PA GA
binding protein a and also called nrf2
this transcribes this transcription
factor T fans who found that this is the
pathway that is probably down big
negative in indica silentium self and
these all these results but he found all
the genes we actually validated so we
did some a functional assay so is ECAR
again is a measure of psychologists or
car is a measure of respirations see we
use two different silencing are raising
is a PK to conceive you not done it
became like holla system down conduction
will go down and so when these two by
artistic processes become slow or goes
down I mean of course the energy
production
and so to mastic analysis but if you're
showing here is the ATP in Eurasian goes
down they TP ATP ratio goes down and in
the h and ratio suppose now because
these ATP ADP entities are produced from
this conference now you know silver
bioenergetics not is not it may or may
not be similar to to my bioenergetics
make sure that what we found vitro is
also true in below so as you can see we
grew tumors that are proficient - maybe
k or deficient okay we took the tumor
tissue out and repeat the same
experiment and we basically
validated or in vitro data in vivo as we
can call it it's below because we took
the tumor tissue out and measure the
localization opposite consumption
validating that a big is required for
tumor by our genetics in the children so
what we have shown so far that ain t ke
prati augments here from alpha and gap
DPA transcription these probably
regulates psychologist American function
we haven't done you know if an alpha and
get be a function was confirmed but more
activity as a mic if as a silencing RNA
over expression rescue experiments so
essentially what we found that in peak
is somehow positively drive each of
these are mastering ultimately regulate
so we we couldn't find any direct
connection between NPK and if one alpha
P a so we thought this potentially
common player that is functioning
between a PK and these two molecules so
so this is a I'm just looking to step
back a bit so this is one experiment
that we that we did to show that this is
a single molecule fish it's common
especially knowing that the - other
transcription so each red dot is
potentially a single
if one mRNA as you can see the control
cells there is a lot of people another
transcript for you to knock down a PK
later consumption goes down so so coming
back to what is this molecule that is
linking in to get in front of - you know
several analysis including analysis and
provide mighty
experiments you know chips he didn't
looking for at the tips of data it's
already published by found that this is
potentially another construction factor
called creme on creme what is a key very
interesting because creme bond is
actually expressed very high in GBM
compared to brain but you know there are
publications that were that came out
long before our study that shows that in
GBM preparation is very high uh we
actually found sign in crab is serine133
that and this is this sequence look
potential target for name peak of
operation because it really matches the
NPA consensus site so we have pacifies
that and he began potentially
phosphorylates the serine133 in crab and
activated and that for friction causes
CREB activation so bottom line is
essentially what that's what he found
so this is control as this is control
tumor this is in silence tumor you can
see this phosphate signaling goes down
in the tumor we do a reverse experiment
we take the normal human astrocytes may
be in peak activation and you can see
the phosphor crab levels grown goes up
so in decay activation causes increased
crab phosphorylation and NPK silencing
can decrease so when we actually use now
that we has a question now if crab is
important then if you're not done crab
will the glycolysis the respiration go
down exactly that's what happens if you
not know crab in that colors goes down
she goes down and we actually next took
one more step to understand if this
phosphorylation event is really critical
for example if you mutate this site and
such that it cannot phosphoric serine at
133 then then you probably able to
rescue the animals for example he will
actually block the tumors to grow and
the animals will live for a long time so
that's exactly what we found
so if you actually do a site directed
mutagenesis of this site from s to hey
now this site cannot be followed by a
bouquet you can see that while the
control and was dyed by this 17 many of
these animals where we responded tumors
expressing this mutant crab now lives
longer so this was the pathway that
finally proposed that I am vegan
phosphorylates and BK although it
includes Empress she won the same time
it was all its crab and label x gb my
registers in survival we recently
published his images for biology last
year and my new postdocs actually is
continuing this project to work on the
next so so what we have shown so far
this is what what I think about how
indicate functions in a tumor I think
it's a context dependent tumor
suppressor when I say it was pressed
each member is deleted that was
oppressive function which is kind of
dependent so what I think is that you
know doing you know the first days of
cancer formation this thing with tumor
formation
I think the cells we put are pretty
pretty really fast and during the time
maybe there is a low-end ticket to be
about yourself they could be some
improves active indicate poles that are
regulating cell cycle surveillance and
problem mitosis of the cells but as the
tumor grows and with rise of similar in
tumor heterogeneity and particularly
you pass tumors los tres okay so
stressful the tumor and requires a
balanced refreshment survival and
particularly when the tumors become
really stressed out and big and there
there is a tremendous amount of heat
food and oxygen flux and going on this
box here and humor acidification oxidant
stress I think during this time a pka
activation potentially you know not
maybe all regions of the team or at
least subdomains the tumor provides
metabolic plasticity to the tumor and
gives a girl thinks about active tumor
so published a study and as I said we
are continuing with some unanswered
questions of the study now I would
switch quickly do another project that
they've been working on recently
published years ago so the self you've
seen here are you know considered as
cell of origin of brain tumors that's
just a terribly long so these cells are
astrocytes of your stem cells is very
very clear cells it could be little
cells what you're seeing here is the
human particular system is in the adult
brain you can see that this is a lateral
ventricle and this is a fourth ventricle
and this lateral ventricle you can see
the red dots these are the potential
signs of the neural stem cells and you
can see that the numbers are the
percentage of patients that get tumors
in this areas for example people there
were forty percent of the GM's in the
front row there is a small but very
important region called brain stem and
also ponds and tumors can develop in
this region too now unlike this area is
mostly cerebral cortex
when Coomer developed in many cases that
humor can be respected being a surgeon
can go ahead and debulk me pick the bulk
of the tumor cut but if a human develops
in the palm to the brain stem because
this area is really critical that
regulates our heartbeat or respiration
this area is inoperable so if a coumarin
develops here the surgery is not an
option so it's basically chemotherapy
and radiation and this has partially
children get this tumor in the brain
stem and because it's named called
series called pons
the tumor is called diffusion in the
tumors actually very diffuse it doesn't
have a boundary
it's called diffuse intrinsic contantly
amount as you can see this is survival
of children with pediatric cancer is
five year to five year survival rates
you can see that we've been pretty good
for example stoma and overalls 82% and
see that this is this is acute leukemia
Moneyball with DIPG is less so it's
dismal the situation really dismal
fortunately so much rare disease that
many of the tumors but once you get it
really there's no cure for it so we know
Hospital we try to understand the
biology of the tumor so this is what you
can see top see a two-year-old child and
we try to drive cell lines from these so
we were able to drive severe intense a
line from this piece of tissue that we
obtained from a Thompson tissue and we
tested the we tested that emergency of
the cells but before that we tested some
of the properties of the cell or markers
these cells Express as you can see that
this adherent cells Express and I'm all
you know
at least important markers of stem cell
is nesting socks too but not another
monitor :
- which is expressed by this sphere
cells so as you as I told before we
there are two different lines one is
adherence lines closing ceremonies serum
independent line so it is believed that
these type of culture this type of
culture actually allows the more stem
like cells to grow but you know
regardless of whether this is a stem
cell of the system so the only
difference between the two that we found
based on the marker expression that we
gave is the absence of only two and
cookies not a Pollock two in these cells
so when we try to forcefully
differentiate these cells as you can see
that some of the cells that
differentiate expresses the
differentiation marker which is GF a B
in this case and found the cells that
are exclusively green in the nucleus
these are the cells are expressing only
two and they're actually but even a lot
tend to differentiate so we think that
you know having only two is a function
of aberrant differentiation so if you
don't differentiate the right time in
the brain that these cells will continue
to proliferate and maybe give rise to
cancer so we tested the ability of these
cells body cells to form tumor in the
brain and we found that the original
tumor patient this only two was
expressed by a very high level switching
so we transplanted these cells to the
brain and these cells were not able to
form tumors okay remember this hellstone
express ecology when we transplant in
these cells each and every animal found
is human tumor in the brain stem so
remember these cells Express so we
thought that maybe and only two is very
important for tumor formation and within
the tumor we saw that every single cell
was expressing molecules so we took the
cells we silenced only two and asked if
the tumors were former not and of course
you can see that the control cells you
see very big tumors of the brain when
you saw us only two it actually really
suppresses and delays tumor growth
it gives a tremendous survival advantage
to the so from this study we have
published a study gene was so this is
technician your lab and he was
instrumental in carrying out all the
studies we published study published
this in Iran Kali in 2017 so I'm going
to stop now for the benefit of time and
mother acknowledge me she my former post
awfully most of the study that was
published in meteorology became breaking
of our genetics Nicole is working on a
very important project on accidental
deletion of genes which I couldn't tell
it today due to the short time Lunia has
a recent system she's helping with
various projects dummy is an
undergraduate training my lab yeah and
is a new rotating undergrad receives a
postdoc in Milan and Vita is not current
postdoc and she's working she's
continuing with the MK study and she has
other projects also Anushka she's
working on a project and she's not and
this is my funding I use to hell with
several other cancer-free kids and
several other institutions of public art
from hospital and the UC brain tumor
Center and these are my collaborators
without you know without their help
I don't think any of our studies would
be successfully done so I'm really
indebted to my cleverness my
collaboration sites Cincinnati
Children's Hospital and meet a
throughout the world and just I won't
end with this light we had a great lot
of fun we went to this Mexican
restaurant for lunch
this was addition during the summer is
Jose he was the rotating graduate
student Bianca is also a grad student
he's a collaborator get some stuff done
in our lab and then was a high school
student and he came to the summer
training and he is now on under
Columbia all right so thank you very
much for attention and a few questions
please feel free to ask me
yeah sure can you just yeah
again it's can you double-click on the
screens chat please okay yeah thank you
so it's a good presentation so I have
just one question like its general maybe
I I do not know much about the subject
so you are talking about most of it is
mpk activation of these various
transcription factors right right so NPK
is in the cytosol if I am NOT wrong is
also it is also nuclear so you see like
any difference in those likely when do
you get the activation of that because
most of the at activation of
transcription factors border or whatever
is there get phosphorylated and then
activates the transcription actually you
know for transcription factors to get
phosphorus the kinase doesn't always
have to be in place because
transcription factors you can actually
translocate proteins including
transcription factors to the nucleus by
forwarding them in the cell class okay
so for example found that CREB for
example we found that if you actually in
the normal cell there is some crab in
the nucleus some crevices in the
cytoplasm I mean the moment you cause in
peak activation we found that a majority
of possible crab is actually present in
cytoplasm
so this technically shows that this
transcription factors can you know
shallow that we set up azimuth you
please say you are affecting these the
phosphorylated Clair's affects the
transcription right other genes
downstream so did I go to that do
go to the nucleus then like I mean I
mean like this I wanted to just get the
idea of like a how'd it happen
yeah so what we found is that the acting
prep the phosphor crap actually binds to
the promoter region of gab and it also
binds to enhance a region in this one
alpha and potentially that's how it
actually promotes okay that's it I think
you need to rush I guess it's almost
time so thank you very much that's what
I really appreciate it and look forward
to your more work on replicas journals
and a good luck okay thank you thank you
very much thank you thank you
[Music]